Priya Singh: Today’s focus: mobile navigation improvements.
Avery Kim: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for mobile navigation improvements.
Avery Kim: UX needs a final pass on mobile navigation improvements.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for mobile navigation improvements.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Jordan Patel: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on mobile navigation improvements.
Noah Williams: My take is we split mobile navigation improvements into two subtasks.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Riley Chen: From design side, We need to align with capacity.
Jordan Patel: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: My take is we split mobile navigation improvements into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, We need to align with capacity.
Riley Chen: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, Security review is likely.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: We need to timebox the spike on mobile navigation improvements.
Riley Chen: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Avery Kim: My take is we split mobile navigation improvements into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Noah Williams: Risk: data migration for mobile navigation improvements.
Jordan Patel: Risk: flaky tests for mobile navigation improvements.
Jordan Patel: Let’s capture action items clearly on mobile navigation improvements.
Samira López: Infra-wise, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Priya Singh: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: My take is we split mobile navigation improvements into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: write migration.
Samira López: Risk: flaky tests for mobile navigation improvements.
Riley Chen: I propose we split mobile navigation improvements into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: create test plan.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: I think we split mobile navigation improvements into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on mobile navigation improvements.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Priya Singh: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on mobile navigation improvements.
Jordan Patel: Action: book design review.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Riley Chen: Action: create test plan.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Let’s clarify acceptance criteria.
Samira López: Let’s keep this within this sprint on mobile navigation improvements.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on mobile navigation improvements; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for mobile navigation improvements.
Noah Williams: From design side, Security review is likely.
Samira López: Okay, who can take ownership?
Samira López: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Avery Kim: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.